I think having a really good lawyer is
the first step an excellent corporate
lawyer really understands the problems
of small companies but also understands
big company practices and that's so
that's worth every dollar you can pay
and some lawyers are entrepreneurial
they will they will agree to be paid in
stock in the beginning in order to work
with a really exciting fast-growing
company and my lawyer did that so i
would say having a really good lawyer in
place but then having contracts in place
when you hire a person for a project
even if you're just paying them in stock
make sure that you have a contract with
that person and that you follow through
with them and you actually make sure
that they're that that the project is
being done as you wanted it to be done
don't just make it this wide um very
open-ended project I always hire
professional services people through
referral so it's always important to
talk to other small business centers and
people will give you referrals to
excellent professionals such as
accountants and lawyers and IP
intellectual property lawyers you're
going to need different types for
different things and so this lawyer came
through a referral I would never use
anybody who I didn't i didn't get at
least one or two excellent comments from
clients that they had worked with
everything we've done has been word of
mouth so
a lot of people spend a lot of money
when they get it I got funding and a lot
of CEOs I know I spent that money on
marketing I believed that the customer
really should lead the company not the
other way around so I've always felt
that if the customer really loves your
product or service they're going to
spread the word for you and so I
probably took a little longer to get to
really get momentum than many companies
do because of that but my company my
type of company is hard to replicate the
barriers to entry are pretty high you
have to really have the goodwill and the
love and the the relationships in order
for that company to thrive so that's
what kept us going for 10 long years or
more most of these companies pop up and
they disappear they're like mushrooms in
the forest right how do you stay and how
do you become a redwood instead of a
mushroom is really the question and i
would say that getting the love of those
customers and and working on the
relationships of the customers even if
it means a slow or startup is much
better in the long run and you last
longer and that's what we've done the
way we spread the word through is
through the cocktail parties we've had a
lot of offline events as well as our
online features and products and
services so it's important to have an
offline component when you have an
online company I can't emphasize that
enough a lot of people think oh I'm
going to start up on the web and it's so
low cost and so easy there's no barrier
to entry so I'm just going to put up a
website and spend a lot of money on
marketing and get traffic and then sell
banner ads but that's not really the
best way necessarily i believe the other
way to do it is to go a little slower to
have offline events offline meetings
with your customers find out deeply do
market research what do they really want
what will they pay for what you know how
can you change their lives and then you
provide those services online great so
you've got the offline component and the
online constantly feeding each other
constantly marketing each other because
every time we put an online thing up a
new product or service we then mark
through our email newsletters to people
who want to come to our cocktail parties
and offline events so it works together
investors don't always believe every
single aspect of your business plan is
what is necessary they always think they
know best but my investors were too busy
and they were frankly really busy so
they didn't bug me a lot about the exact
house and wears and winds of my
marketing plan they just said as long as
you're growing and as long as you can
show growth in your revenue streams will
leave you alone and let you do it the
way you want to do it and I was a little
afraid frankly when I got bought by
Jupiter media that they were going to
try to throw out you know all the
wonderful practices that we started with
but they have it so I think we've been
lucky in both our investors and in the
people who bought us if they their
business as well